hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision medicine using
genotype to inform prescribing presented
by dr. Larissa Cavallari an associate
professor and the director at the Center
for pharmacogenetics University of
Florida College of Pharmacy i'm susie
valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by elaborates
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and type the questions
into the drop-down box that appears on
your screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the help desk button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
educational credits please click on the
accreditation button located on a
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain those credits without further ado
join me in introducing and presenting
our speaker today dr. Larissa Cavallari
I will now turn the presentation over to
her welcome dr. Cavallari thank you for
that introduction and for the invitation
to present I'm happy today to talk about
precision medicine I have been doing
research in the area of precision
medicine and specifically looking at
genes that are associated with drug
response for over 15 years and in since
2012 we've started implementing these
discoveries into practice and so what
I'll be sharing today is our experience
from UF health with precision medicine
so if you recall from his State of the
Union address in 2015
former President Obama appeared with his
DNA double helix and this was all really
exciting for those of us who are in this
area of genomic medicine he announced
his precision medicine initiative which
is to use genetic approaches to better
treat and understand disease and he
specifically said I want the country
that eliminated polio and map the human
genome to lead a new era of medicine one
that delivers the right drug or the
right treatment at the right time and
this essentially signaled continued
government support of genomic medicine
which started essentially in the night
in 1991 the Human Genome Project
precision medicine involves the use of
patient specific information including
family history medical history and
environmental factors like diet in
addition to genetic information and
other unique information to personalize
an individualized care precision
medicine really encompasses looking at
predictors of disease risk and assisting
with disease diagnosis as well as
assisting with a drug treatment based on
based on patient specific factors and
here that really encompasses both cancer
genetics where various institutions are
sequencing the tumor tissue and then
based on the variants that are
identified choosing the best
chemotherapy for the patient and then
pharmacogenetics which is the what I'll
be talking about today
is the association between germline
variants and response to drug therapy so
genes in terms of drug response really a
peg drug response by either influencing
the pharmacokinetics or pharmacodynamics
of a drug so in the case of
pharmacodynamics the genotype can
influence the sensitivity to a drug and
this can affect how beneficial the drug
is or how affected the drug is in
addition to risk for adverse drug
effects in terms of pharmacodynamics the
genotype can help influence how the drug
is distributed throughout the body and
eliminated from the body and this can
help define the dose that is needed
for an optimal effect or to minimize
risk of having an adverse effect and
what I'll be predominantly focusing on
are is the pharmacogenetics around the
metabolism of drugs this is what's been
most clinically implemented into
practice in terms of how the gene might
affect drug response it really depends
on two main factors one is if the drug
is given in its active form it has to be
inactivated by the body and/or it's can
be administered as a pro drug where it
has no activity in its
administer form but then the body
transforms it to the active drug and
then responds or the effective genotype
also depends on whether the gene leads
to increase metabolism or to decrease or
no metabolism of the drug so for example
if you have an active drug and a
genotype associated with increased
metabolism and you can rapidly
metabolize that drug to its inactive
form and the drug may not be effective
in usual doses on the other hand if you
give an active drug or drug in its
active form and you have the genotype
associated with decreased to know
metabolism then you can develop super
therapeutic concentrations of the active
drugs and be at risk for adverse drug
effects and then an opposite extreme if
you give a drug as a pro drug and there
are a number of drugs including a couple
we'll talk about today they're
administered as pro drugs and they have
to be activated within the body to the
active form that then produces the
pharmacologic effects and in this case
if you have increased metabolism then
you can rapidly convert the drug to its
active form and this can lead to super
therapeutic plasma concentrations of the
drug and increased risk for adverse
effects if you have a genotype
associated with decreased or no
metabolism then you cannot activate the
drug or you activate it just a little
bit and this could lead to decrease drug
effectiveness so we currently have over
150 drugs that have genetic information
in their fda-approved labeling and these
drugs really spanned multiple diseases
in some cases or drugs to treat
cardiovascular disease like coumadin or
Klaipeda Grell in other cases these are
drugs
in our logic supporters like tegretol or
infectious disease such as a back of the
year for HIV there are cancer drugs like
more captive hearing and then also drugs
for cystic fibrosis and pain management
others so really expands multiple
disease states in terms of the
medications that have genetic
information in their labeling and where
this genetic information can appear also
varies among different drug products so
for some drugs the genetic information
is in this box warning section of the
label which is the most serious section
of the label or a series kind of warning
I show here with tegretol there is a
variant in the HLA B gene that increases
risk for serious cutaneous reactions
from the drug mainly stevens-johnson
syndrome or toxic epidermal necrolysis
and these variants at HLA B are more
common in individuals from certain Asian
countries and so the Box warning sets
basically say that patients with
ancestry and genetically at-risk
populations should be screened for the
presence of this HLA B variant and if
they test positive then tegretol should
be avoided we're only used if the
benefit clearly outweighs the risk for
other drugs like for coumadin or what
also called warfarin or thiopurines this
information is in the dosage
administration section of the label so
shown here is a dosing table in the
warfarin labeling the B core c1 genotype
which codes for the target protein is on
the left-hand column and then the SIP
2c9 genotype which metabolizes the drug
is across the top so if you look at the
B core C 1 G G genotype which is the
less sensitive genotype in normal
metabolism which is designated as star 1
star 1 and the recommendation is to
start fine - 7 milligrams per day with
lower doses used in older individuals or
those of smaller body size and then an
opposite extreme if you have an
individual with a a genotype the highly
sensitive genotype and decrease
metabolism then they may need a dose as
little as 0.5 to 2 milligrams a day to
reach therapeutic anti
elation so here at um health and many
other institutions across the country we
really rely on guidelines by C pick to
let us know which gene drug pairs are
ready for clinical implementation so C
stands for clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation consortium and it was
formed back in 2009 as a collaboration
between the pharmacogenetics research
Network and the pharmacogenomics
knowledge base and it was recognized at
one of the major barriers to
implementing pharmacogenetics and
practice is there aren't there is a
bunch of guidance on how to use that
information to optimize therapy so this
is what C pick is designed to address
the guidelines do not say whether or not
you should order a genetic test this is
left to the discretion of the provider
but rather if you have genetic results
available they should be used to
optimize drug therapy see fit guidelines
are available for drugs that have the
strongest genetic associations with
response and it for the most part of all
of the implementations that you have
helped which are shown on this slide
they have CP guidelines that are
available
the exception is sip to see 19 for
proton pump inhibitors in this case we
do not yet have CP guidelines we felt
that the data were strong enough to
support using genotype to dose these
drugs and actually we're now on a
writing committee for C pick guideline
focused on PP is so those will be coming
out probably within the next year we
launched our program here in 2012 the
first genotype that we started
genotyping our patients for was
cytochrome p450 to see 19 or sip to see
19 which is involved in the bio
activation of clopidogrel we have since
expanded our testing to our Jacksonville
campus in 2016 where we also test for
sip to see 19 to determine response to
clopidogrel and then we've also
implemented testing to determine
response to other drugs such as
thiopurines which were used for
pediatric cancers as well as some GI and
other disorders opioids for pain peg
interferon alpha
hepatitis C we genotype for two variants
to help with determining selection and
dosing of co2 selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors used for depression
and we predominately use this in our
pediatric psychiatry clinic here and
then most recently with sip TC 19
testing to help with PPI dosing so
notably in 2013 we were awarded funding
as part of the ignite network this is
funded through NHGRI the National
Institutes of genome research or the
Genome Research Institute and ignite
stands for implementing genomics and
practice and the goal of that is really
to move all these genetic discoveries to
patient care so we got this funding in
2013 and it's largely helped support the
implementations we've done since then so
as I mentioned the first drug that we
started with was clopidogrel this is a
drug that is used very commonly for
patients who have had an acute coronary
syndrome or heart attack or undergone
keep percutaneous coronary intervention
or angioplasty and the drug helps keep
the platelets from sticking together and
by preventing this platelet aggregation
it can decrease risk of having a
recurrent heart attack or stroke as well
as on preventing from BOCES of any stent
that might be placed in the coronary
artery so this is a prodrug has no
activity on its own
it must be metabolized to its active
form and sit to c19 has a major role in
that bio activation so it's so to show
that more clearly this is a figure from
the pharmacogenetics knowledge base so
it's freely available just go to
pharmgkb org and this shows that once
clopidogrel enters the body and it
reaches the liver then the majority of
the drug is metabolized by carboxyl
esterase to an inactive metabolite that
is eliminated from the body and it's
only about 15% of the drug that remains
this undergoes a two-step bio activation
process via multiple sip 450 enzymes to
its active metabolite that then
irreversibly binds to the platelet p2y
12 receptor to prevent late
let activation and aggregation sim to
see 19 is involved in both steps of this
bio activation process and it's very
important for generating the active
metabolite individuals who inherit a
deficiency in the enzyme because of
their genotype may have decreased
formation of the active metabolite and
therefore decreased effectiveness of
Quetta grow and inhibiting platelet
aggregation the gene step to see 19 is
highly polymorphic we use this star
allele nomenclature to designate various
polymorphisms in the genome so in the
case of SIP to see 19 the star 2 and
star 3 alleles occur as a result of
single nucleotide polymorphisms or snips
that either lead to a splicing defect or
stop codon and essentially to a complete
loss of enzyme function so these are
termed either non-functional alleles or
loss of function alleles star 17 on the
other hand this is a gain of function
allele associate with increase function
it is in the promoter region of the gene
and it leads to increased gene
transcription and then star 1 is
considered the normal allele it's really
an allele of default so if the genotype
or start to star 3 and star 17 and none
of these are found then the patient is
designated to have a star one allele
these various confer 5 different
phenotypes so patients who have the star
1 star 1 genotype so inherited a copy
for both mother and the father of the
normal genotype there are normal
metabolizers individuals with a single
loss of function allele like star 1 star
2 or star 1 star 3 have a significant
reduction in enzyme activity and are
intermediate metabolizers
those with 2 loss of function alleles
like the star 2 star to genotype are
poor metabolizers they have no active
enzyme and then individuals with one or
two star 17 or gain of function variants
are either rapid or ultra-rapid
metabolizers in the case of clopidogrel
the variants that are most important are
star 2 and star 3 which lead to loss of
function
and the intermediate and poor
metabolizer phenotypes there are racial
differences in the prevalence of these
phenotypes approximately two to four
percent of those of European or African
ancestry are poor metabolizers with no
1619 enzyme another 25 to 30 percent or
intermediate metabolizers with a
significant reduction in enzyme activity
and then these are much higher in Asians
in the Asian population about 60 to 65
percent of individuals are poor
intermediate metabolizers there have
been a number of studies done mostly
retrospective analyses of randomized
control trial data or RCTs or patient
registries and they've shown that among
patients receiving clopidogrel there's
an increased risk for adverse
cardiovascular events mostly heart
attack or stroke or stent thrombosis in
those with a loss of loss of function
allele compared to those without a loss
of function allele so here this was a
meta-analysis shown on the slide of nine
trials nearly 9700 patients they were
all high risk patients most of them have
had heart attack and almost all of them
underwent coronary intervention or
angioplasty with stent placement to keep
that vessel open the investigators for
this meta-analysis found that the risk
for mace was which stands for major
adverse cardiovascular events consist of
cardiovascular death heart attacks or
stroke was about 1.6 fold greater and
those who were treated with clopidogrel
and had a loss of function variant
purses similar similarly treated
patients without a loss of function
Marian and the risk for stem from BOCES
was nearly three times greater in those
with a loss of function variants so
based on these data and 2010 the FDA
approved revision of the clip it a gray
label so this is now a boxed warning in
the label and it states that there's
decreased antiplatelet effect of clip
integral and patients with - loss of
function alleles that test are available
to identify these patients and that
alternative agent should be considered
since this was this labeling started we
now have significant evidence that
intermediate metabolizers with a single
loss of function allele are also at risk
for decrease of integral effectiveness
the C pick or clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation consortium has published
guidelines for how to use of two t19
testing to guide antiplatelet therapy
these are focused on the high-risk
patients and whom the data are the
strongest so patients with an acute
coronary syndrome designate here is acs
a seemly individuals who've had a heart
attack and undergo pci or coronary
intervention also known as angioplasty
in this high-risk patient population if
you have the genotype and the patient
has one or two loss of function alleles
so they're an AM or PM then the
recommendation is to use an alternative
drug because clopidogrel is not expected
to be effective because you can't bio
activate it and the alternatives that
are recommended are either press a grill
or tike a grill or on the other hand for
normal metabolizers or rapid or
ultra-rapid metabolizers clopidogrel is
expected to be effective and its
standard dose so we implemented testing
for clip integral here at in 2012 we did
this as part of routine care and what
that means is that the test was added to
the standard order set for patients who
have undergone a coronary intervention
and so it's the default test all of our
patients are genotype unless the
physician chooses to deselect that test
the sample is processed for genotype and
our clinical pathology lab and the
results are placed in the electronic
health record we have a clinical
pharmacist who then reviews all the
results and for patients who have a
loss-of-function variant the pharmacist
will follow up with a physician to
recommend alternative therapy and I've
put a citation at the bottom here that
describes this or detail we also built a
best practice advisory in our epic
electronic health record so what happens
is if a physician order scalp integral
and if
patient is known to be a poorer
intermediate metabolizer then this alert
will appear and the alert basically
states that the patient's genotype is
associated with impaired activation of
clippety grille and increased risk for
stent thrombosis after coronary
intervention or other cardiovascular
events we also include recommendations
for these patients so they're prescribed
procedural or tech a girl or we've also
included contraindications to these
drugs and any cautions with them to
really make the process this prescribing
process very straightforward for the
clinician you see the genotype is
actually in smaller print at the bottom
because in most cases the clinton the
clinician doesn't care what the actual
genotype is they just lend it with the
implication of having that two type is
and then from this alert of the
physician can choose to go ahead and
place an order for four press a grill or
psych a girl or or if deemed appropriate
they may want to proceed with
clopidogrel this may be a patient who
has contraindications to the other drugs
so after the first two years of the
program we look back to see how many
people were genotyped and what the
physicians did with the genotype result
so then they actually follow the
recommendation to start alternative
therapy so in the first two years we had
just over 400 patients who underwent
genotyping and 31% of these had a loss
of function allele which is consistent
with the prevalence that I showed
earlier so approximately 2% of patients
were poor metabolizers and 28 29 percent
were intermediate metabolizers
of those with a loss of function allele
or LOF allele as shown on the slide
then alternative therapy was started in
just over half of them so we basically
found that Pikul implementation was
successful in most cases the majority of
time that picked the physician would
change therapy in patients with a loss
of function allele so this was great but
does this really matter clinically so
what we did is we went back to the
medical record for all the patients
who've been genotyped and we looked for
hospitalizations for cardiovascular
events like heart attacks or strokes or
for the occurrence of death the
six-month period following coronary
intervention
and then we compared major adverse
cardiovascular events or mace which is
defined as heart attack stroke death or
synthesis between those with a loss of
function allele treated with clopidogrel
shown in the top red line those with a
loss of function allele treated with
alternative therapy like press a Grail
or take a girl or shut it with the
dotted line and those without a loss of
function allele so the non LOF group
this is shown by that solid dark line
and most of these patients got clipped
hetero and as you can see we found there
is a much higher risk for mace those
with a loss of function allele who were
treated with clip integral versus
alternative therapy and no differences
in outcomes between those with a loss of
function allele an alternative therapy
versus those without a loss of function
allele we also found that most of these
events occurred in that first 30 days
following coronary intervention and this
has major implications for reimbursement
there's now the Center for Medicare
Medicaid Services Hospital reduction
hospital readmission reduction program
and through that for individuals have to
be readmitted in the first 30 days then
that would affect the reimbursement for
that hospitalization so these are the
data that we showed our administrators
to support or together their continued
support of our program so we thought
this was great we showed this in 400
patients but it may not make a real
really clinically meaningful impact on
the field with a relatively small sample
size so we then went to the ignite
network again that stands for
implementing genomics in practice to see
if we could collaborate and have a
bigger study to look at outcomes with
genotype guided antiplatelet therapy so
this network the the goal of it is to
advance genomic medicine and patient
care and there are six funded sites
they're shown in the box on the left
three of those sites are focusing on
pharmacogenomics us at um Vanderbilt
University and Indiana University in
addition to these six funded sites are
also a number of affiliate sites and
what I show here are the sites that are
included in the pharmacogenetics working
group
run that working group and among these
sites that are included in that then
there are seven that are implementing
sip to see nineteen testing into
practice and those are shown by the red
circles here and so what we did is we
went to those sites to see if they
wanted to collaborate and they did and
in each case they recommended
alternative therapy for patients who had
a loss-of-function variant
however it was ultimately up to the
physician on how they use that
information and then there were no
geotech guided recommendations made for
those without a loss of function allele
the groups went back and manually
abstracted data from the electronic
health record undeath or hustles ations
for cardiovascular events in the year
period following PCI we also looked at
medication used specifically on which
antiplatelet agent was used in the
patient at the time of the event or at
the time the last follow-up and the
primary outcome was major adverse
cardiovascular events consisting of all
cause mortality non-fatal MI or heart
attack or stroke
there were a total of 1815 patients who
were included across the seven sites
31.5% had a loss-of-function allele
which is similar to what we been up with
in our us cohort and of the 60.5% were
treated with alternative therapy and in
most cases this was press to grow of the
68.5% without a loss of function allele
almost all of them received clopidogrel
almost 85% and alternative therapies
were only used at about 15% of patients
so significantly greater use of
alternative therapy and those with
versus with a loss of function variant
we had very efficient genotyping across
sites the median time from PCI to
genotype results entered into the
medical record was one day and then the
median time to alternative therapy in
those with a loss of function variants
also one day so in terms of results we
saw a significantly greater risk for
major adverse cardiovascular events and
those with a loss of function very
treated with clopidogrel versus those
with a loss-of-function variants retd
with alternative therapy there was no
difference in the risk for mace among
those the loss of function allele an
alternative therapy versus those without
a loss of function allele and again most
of these Ron clopidogrel and then when
we did adjustment we did propensity
scoring to adjust for any differences
between groups and when we did this that
remained a significantly greater risk
for major adverse cardiovascular events
and those with a loss of function
variants treated with clinic rail versus
alternate therapy the hazard ratio was
2.2 and there was no difference in risk
for mace among those with a loss of
function allele an alternative therapy
versus those without a loss of function
variants and these data were published
just this past past month in the Journal
of American College of Cardiology
cardiovascular intervention so Jack see
I
so in summary of this one area we had
data across seven institutions nearly
2,000 patients we showed that clinical
implementation of pharmacogenetic
testing was feasible with rapid return
of genotype results institution of
alternative therapy and those with a
loss of function allele and then
importantly we showed that this genotype
guided approach to antiplatelet therapy
after coronary intervention led to a
significant reduction in major adverse
cardiovascular events so I'm going to
move on and talk briefly about proton
pump inhibitors which are commonly used
for individuals who have gi reflux
disease or h pylori and in this case sip
to see 19 the same enzyme metabolizes
proton pump inhibitors proton pump
inhibitors are administered in their
active form so this is opposite of what
we saw with clip headed grill and then
they have to be bio or they have their
inactivated in the body by the sieve to
see 19 enzyme for individuals who have
increased metabolism so for the rapid
and ultra-rapid metabolizers then they
will quickly have activate the drug and
normal doses may not be effective in
these individuals in
those who have decreased enou metabolism
then the amount of the active drug will
accumulate the body and these
individuals can be at risk for
side-effects traditionally we've thought
that proton pump inhibitors are
relatively benign they're very widely
prescribed in many cases they're
continued for a long period of time but
in recent years there have been data
that shows that this chronic use of pipi
is may increase risk for certain types
of infections poor bone fracture and
also increased risk for kidney disease
so these do not appear to be as benign
as we thought and there's also been an
association between having these
side-effects and higher levels of proton
pump inhibitors in the body so based on
this poor and intermediate metabolizers
are going to have higher levels of
proton pump inhibitors maybe an
increased risk for these adverse effects
so we started testing for 6 to 19 to
guide dosing of ppis in 2017 and at the
same time we started a study to look at
the effectiveness of this approach and
this was done in conjunction with
Nemours Children's Hospital that's
located by the Jacksonville and in
Orlando together we came up with
recommendations for proton pump
inhibitor dosing based on phenotype so
for those who are rapid or ultra-rapid
metabolizer so they have a star 17
allele then the recommendation is to
increase the PPI dose by 50 to 100
percent so if you'll recall we the four
clopidogrel the recommendations for
rapid el tráfico metabolizers are the
same as those for normal metabolizers
because we don't really have data that
rapid ultra-rapid metabolizers respond
much differently than normal
metabolizers in terms of clopidogrel
that's not true here with proton pump
inhibitors they may have a decreased
response with normal doses that's our
recommendation is to increase the dose
and rapid and ultra-rapid metabolizers
for intermediate or poor metabolizers
the recommendation is to reduce the dose
by 25 to 50 percent to help prevent
these adverse effects and these data
we've recently completed a small studies
both in adults here you have health and
in children at Nemours and the
preliminary results from these would be
presented at the ASEP tea meeting
American Society for clinical
pharmacology and therapeutics at this
March so the final example that I want
to talk about is with SIP 2d6 testing
and codeine
so sip to d6 is a very common joint
metabolizing enzyme it metabolizes a
number of different drugs including
opiates in this case codeine tramadol
oxycodone and hydrocodone are
metabolized by 56 to more active
analgesics that have much greater
affinity for the opioid new receptor so
that sort of shown here on on this
picture codeine is a pro drug if you
have the genotype associated with
increased metabolism in this case it's
up to five percent of population then
you can get an increased concentration
of active metabolite which for coding is
morphine and if you have high morphing
concentrations this can lead to an
increased risk for adverse effects
namely respiratory depression and even
death about 10% of the population has
either no active enzyme at all or
significant reduction is I'm activity
these individuals they have either can't
bio activate coding or have very little
bio activation of coding so have very
slow levels of morphine in the body and
they may not get out of what analgesic
effects from coding and we have similar
dated so the same thing is true with
tramadol and probably true to some
extent with hydrocodone and oxycodone
although the data are less clear for
these drugs 686 is also important for
metabolizing antidepressants and
including SSRIs and tricyclics
antidepressants and as I mentioned
earlier in the talk we use sip 2d6
testing to help guide selection of SSRIs
mostly in our Pediatrics psychiatry
patients so there have been a number of
case reports for individuals who were
exposed to codeine and had either severe
respiratory depression or even death
because of the ultra-rapid metabolizer
phenotype so these are two case reports
show here one was a two year old boy he
was prescribed codeine
when Tylenol after a nano tonsillectomy
who is otherwise healthy and he died two
days after surgery an autopsy they found
that he had the 686 ultra-rapid
metabolizer phenotype and toxic morphine
concentrations in his blood the other
case was a healthy male infant who was
being breastfed and he was found dead on
day 12 an autopsy they found that his
concentrations of morphine were the
toxic range his mother was taking
codeine postpartum and she had
ultra-rapid metabolizer phenotype so in
this case she completely converted
codeine and morphine toxic morphine
levels were then transferred to the
infant being pressed by through
breastfeeding and then this led to two
death in this particular patient so very
serious adverse effects and a
responsiveness the FDA has issued a
warning basically restricting the use of
codeine as well as trim at all their
similar data with tramadol restricting
the use of these at any children under
the age of 12 and they also should not
be used in women who are breastfeeding
there are CP guidelines for sip 26 and
codeine these were published in 2014 and
one thing I did not mention earlier all
of these C pick guidelines are freely
available on the web you can either just
google the C pick or you can go to the
pharmacogenomics knowledge based website
which is pharmgkb org and you can get
these these guidelines free of charge so
466 in coding the guidelines recommend
for ultra-rapid metabolizers and poor
metabolizers that you avoid use of
codeine because of the risk for toxicity
and ultra-rapid metabolizers and the
likelihood of having no analgesic effect
and poor metabolizers they also rate the
trim it all should also be avoided in to
a lesser extent hydrocodone and
oxycodone for normal metabolizers of
course it's okay to use codeine and it's
normal age-appropriate recommended dose
for those who are intermediate
metabolizers the guidelines say so you
can use recommended therapy but if they
have a
analgesic response then then use an
alternative agent what we do it you have
health is we actually recommend
alternative agents from the start for
both poor and intermediate metabolizers
because intermediate metabolizers have
such low amount of 686 activity so we
launched genotyping for 686 in July of
2015 so it's clinically available and
can be ordered across our health system
and at the same time we started to study
so that we could help determine whether
the students I guided approach might be
beneficial one of those studies was done
in patients with chronic pain so paying
for at least three months and this was
patients who were enrolled in primary
care clinics here at UF health and also
a couple of clinics in Orlando and then
we have an ongoing trial where patients
are randomized to genotype guided
approach or to usual care or treatment
of cancer related pain in our oncology
clinics so we actually took coding off
of our inpatient formulary here this was
done because of this risk for toxicity
and ultra-rapid metabolizers and we
didn't have genotype yet available so it
was felt that it was best to avoid this
drug
however we build clinical decision
support so that if a physician
prescribes tramadol which is still on
formulary for a patient that has what we
call an actionable genotype so genotype
that would lead to a change in drug
therapy status if deeper poor
intermediate oral trêpa metabolizers
then this this alert will pop up warning
the the physician of either risk for
toxicity or lack of analgesic response
and recommending alternative therapy so
I mentioned the trial that we did in
primary care we actually just recently
completed this trial we enrolled a total
of 480 patients or managed in primary
care clinics with chronic pain of at
least three months duration and they
were randomized in a two to one designed
either a genotype intervention or two
usual pain management the samples were
collected for genetic analysis in both
groups and the genotype group the
genotype was returned in about a week
and the result entered in the medical
record for the usual care group we
genotype them at the end of the study
and all patients completed surveys at
baseline at 3-month the
assess pain intensity and other pain
related measures such as pain
interference physical functioning and
emotional functioning we use this
through the NIH promis measures our
baseline pain score in the study
population was six point seven out of
ten so these patients had a pretty high
burden of pain what we found is that 10%
of these patients are either poor and
our media metabolizers by genotype about
1% we're ultra-rapid metabolizers but if
you took into account drug interactions
we know there are rip drugs that inhibit
the sip 26 enzyme so if you take that
into account which can really kind of
Fino convert them to be a poor
intermediate metabolizers that overall
30% of the patients rather on an
interacting drug or had a genotype that
associated with poor to intermediate
metabolism we have finished analyzing
our data and in terms of clinical
implementation we found that this
approach was feasible to get the genetic
sample and have the genotype result back
within a week to help with drug therapy
changes we also found that it would be
more important if we get a the genotype
available at the time the physicians all
the patients so they have that gene time
they're on hand and therefore they could
they can change therapy as needed the
way we rolled it out with a giant eye
coming back a week later the patient may
not return to the physician for several
more months and so the changes were not
made until that latter visit and they
were actually only made about 31% of the
time for individuals who had an
actionable genotype
however wind changes were made they
strongly adhere to our recommendation so
they followed the recommendations by our
team ninety-seven percent of time so
what happened is when the genotype came
back for the geotech guided group we had
a clinical pharmacist to and write a
consult note informing the physician of
the genotype and any interacting
medications that might decrease the t26
activity and providing a recommendation
for pain management the effect of this
approach on patient reported pain
outcomes particularly pain intensity
will be presented at the ASC PT meeting
the same one we're presenting the PPI
results in March of this year so to stay
tuned for that so while I can't share
those data yet I can share the
experience of one
so this was a patient mr. Cruz who was
in our study and was randomized to the
genotype guided arm when he had a very
high level of pain when he first started
the study
he stated that all he really wanted to
do on the weekends was spend time with
his grandkids but he was just too much
play to really enjoy them so he was
student at this part of the study and
based on his genotype and drug
interactions we recommended a change in
therapy which the physician did and mr.
Cruz basically said you cured me he said
that taking the test really changed his
life this is him at the park with his
grandkids and it's going to change a lot
of people's lives so at least we know we
have touched one person with this
approach so as I mentioned earlier I
leave the Ignite pharmacogenetics
working group which is really an
opportunity for sites across the country
to share our experiences implementation
share data from this which led to our
outcomes study with SIPP to see 19
testing and clip editor I'll use and
we're currently working on a analysis of
56 implementations across sites shown
here are 16 sites in this working group
and the various gene drug payers they
implemented a clinical practice the most
common is zip to see 19 testing for
clinic at the drill which is why that
was the first example that we've studied
you can see a number of sites have also
offers SIPP 2d6 testing for coding or
trim at all they also may do testing
related by a purine dosing selection of
antidepressants and even some testing
for Vora Kaunas all which is an anti
effective agent which is metabolized 360
C 19 so quite a quite a lot of different
imitations across this country and
there's a variety of those going on and
we expect this to only continue to
expand these are representative
publications from our partner page in X
working group the first one shown at top
was just initial description of the of
the group and its opportunity for
building evidence with pharmacogenetic
implementation in this real world
setting so through a pragmatic trial
design the second I showed here is our
recent publications on publication on Al
with the genotype guided approached
antiplatelet therapy after coronary
intervention and then most recently the
group is published a paper on strategies
of implementation of 6:19 testing the
guide antiplatelet therapy and that just
came out I believe in either December or
January we have probably three other
publications in the works one of those
includes a cost-effectiveness analysis
of SIPP to see 19 testing to predict
clopidogrel response we have a website
or the ignite network this is actually
run through UF and I provide the web
link here if you'd like to visit that
and learn more about what the different
sites are doing we also have a tool box
so if you're thinking of implementing
practice you can look for tools that
have been used at other sites such as
different clinical decision support
tools examples of different platforms
used for genotyping and at patient
education materials and that kind of
thing so in summary we the use of
genetic information to guide decisions
about drug therapy will likely continue
to become increasingly common there is a
need to generate evidence on outcomes
with genotype guided therapy so that we
can support sustainability such as the
outcomes data that I shared with SIPP to
see 19 testing and clopidogrel and
pharmacogenetics working group through
ignite as well as there are other
pharmacogenetics working groups with
other large networks provide
opportunities to collectively
disseminate data on outcomes with
pharmacogenetic testing and then I just
like to acknowledge the number of
investigators who have contributed to
the work that I presented today as well
as our funding sources so thank you for
your attention thank you dr. Cavallari
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question drop-down
box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
the question into the box that appears
on the screen and click that send button
so let's take a look at our first
incoming questions currently coming in
from our audience members our first
question is what additional data are
needed to move the field forward okay
thank you that's a great question I
think a big part of it is to show that
geotech guided approaches can be
beneficial for our patients either by
improving clinical outcomes or
decreasing risk or adverse effects
traditionally when you're looking at
these kind of data what's generally
considered the gold standard is a
randomized controlled trial however I
think conducting a randomized controlled
trial for every example of genotype
guided therapy would be quite expensive
and labor-intensive there are a couple
trials going on for example there are at
least two trials looking at a sip to see
19 genotype got it approached
antiplatelet therapy those are expect to
be completed in the next year or two but
I think we have to look to other
mechanisms for gathering this data such
as the pragmatic type of studies that I
presented today so I think that you'll
see going forward that there'll be more
data coming out on outcomes with
pharmacogenetic testing and this may be
what we really need to sustain this
approach to prescribing and also to be
able to secure reimbursement which is
another big obstacle going forward able
to obtain this for third party payer for
the genetic testing our next question
dr. Cavallari is what are the major
lessons you have learned based on your
experience with pharmacogenetics testing
okay I think there are a couple of big
lessons that we have learned one is that
there has to be some kind of clinical
decision support to the physician so
just returning the genotype result back
isn't necessarily going to help we need
some other assistance so whether that is
a clinical pharmacist like we have had
reviews that the genotype results and
provides recommendations directly to the
physician either through a phone call or
consult mode or however that's done or
building electronic clinical decision
support such as the best practice
advisory that I showed but overall we
found that it's just really important
that without having clinical decision
support then it may not lead to
appropriate changes based on the
genotype
I think another big lesson we've learned
is how important it is the habit the
physician to have that genotype on hand
when they're seeing the patient and not
where they're getting a sample than
having to wait awhile for this for the
genotype to come back and so we're
trying to think through approaches where
we can be more preemptive which we know
patients coming to clinic how can we get
their genotype ahead of time so it's
there with the position with our seeing
the patient act on rather than having to
collect the sample then and wait another
three months so the patient comes back
before they're able to act on those XI 2
type results I think those are two of
the big lessons that we've learned in
our experience thank you very much
and I also want to thank our audience
today for their wonderful questions
coming in and remind them that any
question is not answered today will be
answered via email our final question
that we have time for today is dr.
Cavallari what do you see for the future
of pharma pharmacogenetics I think this
this kind of gets back to what I was
talking about with the lessons learned
in that the genotyping needing to be
available at the time that the patient
the physician sees the patient what I
see is the future is that we may move
toward a more pre-emptive genotyping
approach probably for a number of
different genes and variants not just a
reactive approach we're doing now where
we have a patient comes in they need a
particular therapy and so we're
genotyping them them to wait for the
results to come back or we can apply
that to their drug therapy decision I
think moving forward we're going to see
more places offering panel based
pre-emptive testing so that we could
genotype individuals when they're still
relatively healthy or there's not an
urgent need for drug therapy
then they'll have a genotype available
in their medical record should they need
any of the drugs that genotype could be
important for so that's where I see
things moving toward I think in a lot of
ways this will be driven by patients
patients who may want this kind of
information in their medical records to
assist with their drug theory a major
challenge or barrier right now is there
no there's no reimbursement for this
type of pre-emptive panel based testing
but hopefully in the future we'll see
this become more commonplace because
certainly it makes a lot of practical
sense it also helps save a lot of cost
because there it's very costly so you
have the personnel to rapidly turn
genotype around and you have to have the
luxury of banking samples from multiple
patients and then running those at once
it's a much less costly endeavor so this
is where I see it going they have
currently going on in the UK they have a
clinical trial called the ubiquitous
trial where they're testing this
approach and they're doing this panel
based preemptive testing for their
patients and then seeing how often that
that information is used to guide drug
therapy and see whether or not it might
lead to decreased risk for adverse
effects and better outcomes and patients
who have such data available thank you
very much dr. Cavallari did you want to
add any closing remarks before we close
our webinar today I think just overall
this is pharmacogenetics as sort of them
are actionable of the different genomic
medicine initiatives that are going
forward we have a lot of data to support
it I think we'll see it being used in
practice more and more there is some
controversy on the type of evidence
that's needed to support pharmacogenetic
implementation there's one camp and we
fall into that here at you have help
that says the genotype is really another
laboratory test similar to measuring
someone's kidney function that we do all
the time without any randomized control
trial data it's really just another test
to help us choose better therapy for the
patient there's another camp that really
wants the randomized control trials to
try to get results that showed the
genotype
approach improves outcomes but I think
going forward we'll see more results
coming out from pragmatic studies who
have already implemented into testing
the state it will be important to
support sustainability of the field and
I think maybe eventually this
pharmacogenomics can pave the way for
other gene based interventions to occur
including greater use of genetic
information for disease risk or
predicting disease phenotype and even
assisting in disease diagnosis Cavallari
thank you again for your presentation
and for your important research I'd also
like to thank the lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
on demand through May 2018 you'll
receive an email from Labrador this
webcast will be available for replay
please share the announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's it for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye